le
janvier en egypte est une journée fériée
c'est pas une fête religieuse d'une fête
d'historique
c'est la fête de la police cette journée
vise à célébrer le courage et
l'abnégation de cette belle institution
pour protéger le peuple égyptien le 25
janvier 2011 était donc prévu des
parades et des défilés mais ça c'est pas
tout à fait passé comme prévu
mais si vous le voulez bien revenons six
mois en arrière
à la fin de mes études d'ingénieur je
décide de voyager un petit peu de faire
le tour de la méditerranée et j'arrive
au caire pour retrouver des amis
égyptiens leur rendre visite je pensais
rester de trois semaines
j'y suis resté finalement plus de deux
ans ce que je découvre en arrivant c'est
déjà justement la présence de la police
partout dans toutes les rues dans tous
les bâtiments à tous les croisements
partout il ya des policiers et partout
également à la télé dans la rue dans la
radio hosni moubarak
le tyran local je comprends donc
rapidement fait que la l'egypte est bien
une dictature policière
mes amis alliés à thèmes notamment
m'accueille et au bout de quelques jours
m'explique que pile le jour de mon
arrivée a été retrouvé le corps sans vie
de khaled saïd dans une ruelle
d'alexandrie khaled said avait été
arrêté par les policiers est battu à
mort pendant son interrogatoire il
pensait que c'était un deal ans de recul
sauf que khaled said n'était pas du tout
un dealer de drogue
khaled saïd était un jeune étudiant qui
aimait boire des bières avec ses amis et
draguer des filles sur internet et ce
qui ressemblait un fait au profil de
toute la jeunesse égyptienne donc son
cas était largement médiatisées les
brutalités policières étaient monnaie
courante mais c'est là particulièrement
a beaucoup choqué du coup pour lui
rendre hommage
un groupe facebook a été créé we are all
khaled saïd qui s'est employé à diffuser
des informations
contestant le régime est
particulièrement les brutalités
policières en ligne
et hors ligne à fédérer un peu les
mouvements de contestation qui
existaient contre le régime des
mouvements étudiants des mouvements
syndicalistes du mouvement communiste
etc
j'ai trouvé finalement un poste
d'enseignant en mathématiques dans un
lycée francophone je me suis donc
installé en egypte et continue à
m'intéresser à la vie locale et en
novembre j'étais donc là pour les
élections parlementaires il ya un
parlement en egypte et les collections
d'avant qui a vu une petite ouverture
avec des candidats de l'opposition
notamment issu des frères musulmans qui
avaient été élus en penser que peut-être
cette dynamique d'ouverture allait
continuer on a été rapidement déçu le
98% des bulletins était pour le npd les
triche électorale ne sont même pas caché
donc tout espoir de changement
démocratique classique par les urnes a
été complètement douché ce jour là enfin
le pour moi le troisième événement
important c'est la chute de ben ali
qu'on voit ici à droite à côté moubarak
à la suite si vous vous rappelez de
l'immolation de mohamed bouazizi ce
jeune vendeur de rue tunisiens qui sujet
à la même brutalité policière qu'en
egypte s'est immolé a déclenché de
grandes manifestations qu'on a beaucoup
suivi en egypte et qui à la surprise
générale au bout de trois semaines on
fait partir ben ali qui encore une fois
très amis et qu'on barak le même trente
ans de régime dictature policière pareil
hélas les égyptiens se sont dits tout le
monde s'est dit mes amis mais tiens
pourquoi chez eux pourquoi pas chez nous
et ce fameux groupe facebook ou un rôle
khaled saïd a profité de ce climat
ces événements pour lancer un appel à
manifester sur ce fameux 25 janvier 2011
profiter de cette journée fériée pour
organiser une manifestation contre la
brutalité policière
on est en 2011 quand on veut lancer une
manifestation qu'est ce qu'on fait on
crée un événement facebook et grand
grand grand engouement pour cet
événement je me souviens l'avoir
consulté l'avoir découvert
à peu près une semaine avant il y avait
plus de 50000 personnes qui étaient
marquées comme intéresser tout le monde
en parle et les amis égyptiens mes amis
français
même les élèves de 1re pas les plus
politisés
monsieur vous avez vu qu est ce que vous
pensez qu'il va se passer j'en sais rien
personne n'en savait rien personne ne
savait quoi attendre de ce moment un peu
unique
donc est ce qu'on a fait on a fait un
peu comme tout le monde on est descendus
dans la rue ce 25 janvier et on l'a
attendu voir ce qui se passait on
s'attendait peut-être avoir un groupe
d'une cinquantaine de personnes comme
les manifestations habituelles là bas
qu'elle est rapidement réprimé dispersés
par la police
est ce qu'on a vu ce n'est pas 50
personnes ce qu'on a vu c'est emile 2000
personnes en fait ce qu'on a appris
après c'est que les organisateurs de ce
fameux groupe ou rôles khaled said
s'étaient formés à des techniques de
manifestations beaucoup plus efficace et
donc avait réussi rapidement atteindre
une masse critique de manifestants une
masse sécurisante qu'on a rejoint et on
était plein et on était tous surpris
d'être là on savait pas vraiment où
aller et on est arrivés finalement à
cette fameuse place tahrir
cette place de la libération et on s'est
retrouvé là vingt mille personnes les
quelques forces de sécurité qui étaient
présentes étaient complètement dépassés
son parti et d'un coup on s'est
retrouvés et on s'est dit bon voilà
c'est gagner on voulait manifester où on
a pris cette place on peut dire ce qu'on
pense on dit non brutalité policière et
l'atmosphère était festive joyeuse sas
interpellait savent chanter à danser
tout le monde était tellement surpris
d'être là de pouvoir dire ce qu'il
pensait c'était unique le soir même les
quelques gens qui étaient restés pour
occuper la place sont faits dégagés par
les forces de sécurité et un appel a été
lancé à manifester à nouveau le vendredi
pourquoi elle vendredi dans les pays
musulmans le vendredi c'est la journée
fériée
c'est la prière du vendredi un peu comme
la prière du dimanche chez nous et donc
l'appel était après les prières ont
rejoint les cortèges et on va manifester
on va reprendre tahrir
je me souviens la veille au soir
justement avec ali hatem et d'autre on
était un peu fébrile internet venait
d'être coupée on savait que les
portables allaient être coupées
on avait bricolé quelques bandol un peu
humoristique on était joyeux on était
content vivre on savait pas trop ce que
ça allait être mais on était content
donc le 28 ont rejoint les cortèges avec
nos pancartes ou joyeux sauf que nous on
s'était bien préparé mais les policiers
aussi c'était mieux préparés et les
manifestations étaient beaucoup plus
violente que celle du 25 canons à eau
lacrymogènes chevrotine également j'en
ai reçu une dans le front mon ami ali on
a pris huit dans la jambe beaucoup plus
de combats on n'était pas préparé à ça
mais on voulait reprendre tahrir ce
qu'était notre droit aller manifester
sur cette place et à la fin de la
journée
ça y est on avait repris tahrir
l'atmosphère était moins festive moins
joyeuse mais fier on était là et cette
place sont à la carte et le campement
s'est organisée je suis retourné tous
les jours sur tahrir quasiment ce qui
m'a beaucoup marqué dès le début c'est
l'auto organisation des manifestants
spontanément des groupes se créent pour
gérer les entrées gérer
l'approvisionnement en eau gérer la
nourriture installé une scène pour des
débats des chanteurs cette auto
organisation là on n'avait jamais vécu
et les égyptiens m'avait dit on n'a
jamais vu ça avant c'était un endroit de
tout était possible et les les premiers
slogans sont apparus un peu plus
généraux que juste contre la brutalité
policière
le premier char broulis shannon izar le
peuple demande la chute du régime
j'ai pas si vous imaginez la puissance
qui avaient ce slogan c'était par un
petit groupe de personnes qui
demandaient une petite chose non c'était
le peuple égyptien tout entier veut rien
d'autre que la chute de ce régime
dictatorial qui dure depuis bien trop
longtemps
l'autre slogan fédérateur air faraça cfo
wenta masri relève la tête tu es
égyptien relève la tête on a mis la tête
dans le sable dans l'autre ont longtemps
relève la tête tu peux être fier d'être
égyptien c'est ton pays c'est ta vie
reprend larmes
ça c'est demande était très forte très
belle et y en avait plein d'autres en
fait n'importe qui sur tahrir s'arranger
pour trouver un bout de papier un
marqueur et écrire des choses je ne veux
plus du service militaire obligatoire
je veux une vraie constitution etc
chaque personne prenait écrivait son
slogan est passée était tellement fier
de pouvoir montrer ce qu'ils pensaient
garder je pense ça est ce qu'on peut en
discuter à l'andi avançons cette
atmosphère est exceptionnel bon là
l'occupation de la place ne s'est pas
passé sans heurts le camp pro moubarak
s'est organisée il ya eu notamment même
jusqu'à des charges de chameau sur les
manifestants de tahrir
c'est assez impressionnant mais
finalement au bout de 18 jours victoire
hosni moubarak quitte le pouvoir
la demande principale de la place tahrir
est acceptée à là c'était la liesse pour
imaginer les la fête toute la nuit les
champs les feux d'artifice on a gagné on
a pu se réunir pacifiquement sur une
place demandé à ce que ce mec est là
depuis 30 ans parti et on a gagné
quel bonheur sauf qu'hosni moubarak est
parti soit il a laissé le pouvoir soit
mais pas des civils
pas des députés où les ministres il a
essayé de pouvoir l'armée bon et l'armée
a un peu traîné les pieds pour lancer un
processus démocratique qui étaient
appelés on est retourné à la tarière
plusieurs fois pour continuer à demander
ça et au bout d'un an on a eu lieu en
egypte les premières élections
présidentielles démocratiques ouvertes
et pour la première fois de toute
l'histoire de l'egypte même depuis le
phare en un civil a été élu à la tête du
pays
ce civil c'est mohammed morsi issu des
frères musulmans bon sauf que son règne
a été de courte durée
le le
il a très mal géré le pouvoir et l'armée
s'est servi un peu du mécontentement
populaire pour organiser à nouveau les
grandes manifestations demandant son
départ et la destituer ce que les
américains ont osé appeler un coup
d'état démocratique
une des premières décisions de l'armée
les frères musulmans s'étaient organisés
à nouveau en sit in pour demander le
retour de mort si une des premières
grandes décisions de l'armée ça a était
d'évacuer ces campements ces sit in par
la force c'est le massacre de rabat
amnesty international deux entre 800 et
1000 morts en une seule journée
c'est qu'ils ont fait quand même un sac
pire que tiananmen mais l'armée avait le
le peuple avec lui l'opinion générale
est assorti de ses rangs un jeune et
fringant maréchal le match chelsea qui a
repris le pouvoir qui a été élu très
grande majorité et qui est actuellement
encore le dirigeant de l'egypte
je suis retourné j'étais parti juste
après l'élection de mortier pour des
raisons personnelles je suis retourné en
egypte il ya quelques mois au printemps
pour voir un peu comment comment s'est
passée la vie maintenant tous ici et
j'ai retrouvé beaucoup de choses de
l'époque de moubarak
la police est revenue l'état policier
revenus des des checkpoints partout des
contrôles des fouilles et c'est toute
voix dissidente est complètement tu es
réprimer les frais disent les frères
musulmans bien sûr les activistes
révolutionnaire également mais même les
journalistes beaucoup beaucoup de mal de
plus en plus de mal à faire leur métier
même toutes les ong ont vu leur champ
d'action complètement limité et aussi
légué les athées toute voix dissidente
et férocement un crime et 6 il va même
plus loin que moubarak
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre
actuellement il ya entre 400 et 600
personnes qui sont disparus des
activistes qui pendant la nuit
disparaissent et en reviennent parfois
au bout de quatre mois j'étais dans une
prison de désert je sais pas où donc
finalement le l'ancien régime est revenu
et est même revenu encore plus fort donc
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que finalement
ça n'a servi à rien tout cette lutte
tous se tarir tous ces manifestations c
est mort parce qu'il y en a eu c'est ce
que vous pouvez vous dire d'ailleurs
tout ça n'a servi à rien bon ça n'a pas
servi à rien ça n'a pas servi à rien ça
a marqué à jamais toute cette tout ce
peuple égyptien j'en prends pour exemple
la scène culturelle
il y avait une scène culturelle
alternative sous moubarak mais vraiment
petit
et elle a vraiment bourgeonner éclos
explosé même après la révolution elle
est toujours là le nombre de groupes de
musique
le nombre de troupes de théâtre le
nombre de compagnies de danse l'ombre de
festivals d'envergure internationale n'a
rien à voir avec qui avait avant sous
moubarak scène culturelle est là pour
rester ça c'est un grand plaisir is
évite de parler de sujets extrêmement
politique mais l'expression est toujours
là et puis de manière plus générale on a
quand même toute une génération qui à un
moment a osé descendre dans la rue qui a
osé affronter la peur de la police
la peur du système la peur du
découragement général et à oser aller
manifester et dire non je ne veux pas je
veux m'exprimer écouté ma voix et toute
cette génération n'oubliera jamais
regagné un peu en totalise aura perdu en
ft entendeur
cette génération n'aurait jamais oublier
qu'il est possible de descendre dans la
rue et terna est ce que ça m'a appris ce
que l'egypte mahé prix c'est pour ça que
je pense ce t-shirt paraître mince
j'aime l'egypte parce qu'elle m'a appris
que même si on va perdre ça sert
toujours d'aller lutter merci beaucoup
merci et au courage du peuple égyptien